List of reasons why.
I think the passport bros have actually figured it out.
Starting off with number one,
they're looking for traditional women who value family.
Men, other cultures,
other countries put family first
above their needs, above anything else.
Family is very important.
There's nothing wrong with a man who values family
and wants to find a partner who also does.
For two, women in other countries are often very feminine.
They let the man lead. A man will value a feminine woman.
Three. Women in other countries actually very educated.
The huge misconception that women in other countries are poor,
uneducated, that couldn't be further from the truth.
Nothing better than having a partner
who is equally as intelligent as you are.
Number four, these men are seeking women who know how to cook.
Cook for the family is one of the most important things.
Family dinner time, sitting down together,
space it. Most men don't wanna go eat fast food every day.
They want a woman who cooks for them,
who takes care of them and the family.
Passport bros simply just want a soft,
feminine, traditional woman who will cook,
who's intelligent. I don't know. What do you guys think?